[Musique]
restez chez vous
c'est ce qu'on nous a dit le premier
confinement plus de papier toilette plus
de sucre ni de farine dans les rayons
des supermarchés
oui 80 % de la nourriture en france et
distribués dans les grandes surfaces
on parle aussi du risque de la rupture
de la chaîne d'approvisionnement
alimentaire
alors qu'en france c'est au million de
personnes se trouvaient déjà dans la
précarité soit une personne sur dix ne
mange pas à sa faim
spontanément on est descendus dans la
rue pour
commencer à planter des comestibles
on a voulu trouver ne même le début de
la réponse face à la crise alimentaire
sociale climatique et politique c'était
le début de l'aventuré de notre
mouvement citoyen
les jardinières masquer
ce soir plutôt que d'attribuer un visage
sur scène
ne représentant cette mosaïque de
citoyens je suis un nous sommes deux
nous sommes quatre nous sommes des
milliers
chacun avec nos différences mais relié à
une aspiration commune
ayant tout perdu à cette époque sans
aucune aide mais aucune n j'ai rejoint
les nouveaux ports le premier besoin
manger
le deuxième se protéger
mars 2020 pénurie de masques dus au
virus des couturières masqué en
confectionner des milliers de masques et
nous avons rêvé est planté les légumes
et des arbres fruitiers
pour lancer l' alerte de la vie dans la
ville
premier confinement tous les parcs
étaient fermées à clé sauf celui de la
place de strasbourg où nous avons planté
nos premières graines pourtant étant des
personnes si petit oui des radis
puis nous avons investi d'autres lieux
comme lille balzac au milieu de la
rivière puis vint le terrain près de la
rivière un peu sauvage au milieu de la
biodiversité à la gloriette nous y
faisons de l'agroforesterie une cour et
de vergers
des ateliers
un petit peu de stress vous inspire
[Applaudissements]
nous partageons d'être experience lan
traite est mise en place nous avons créé
une charte où il est dit que tout le
monde peut planter peut récolter
entretenir et peut venir aux réunions à
l'organisation participé aux ateliers
aux échanges de connaissances merci
on vit dans un monde où l'on peut
trouver des oignons de nouvelle zélande
dans les supermarchés français
des kiwis pourquoi pas mais des oignons
permettez moi d'insister
considérant cette belle tomate comme
étant notre planète bleue si la france
se trouve ici alors la nouvelle zélande
se trouve là à près de 20 mille
kilomètres
en gros si vous aller plus loin vous
rentrez en france
tout ceci est possible grâce à des
traités de libre échange
alors comment s'étonner après cette
période extraordinaire que nous avons
vécu où tout s'est arrêté même si c'est
un exemple extrême il est pourtant bien
réelle que l'acheminement des
marchandises sont devenues très
compliquées voire inexistant pour
certains pays
j'ai beaucoup voyagé
j'ai eu la chance de sortir des routes
touristiques et je me suis aventuré loin
pour m'occuper de la nature et j'ai pu
constater voir par mes propres yeux la
destruction des terres ancestrales qui
est sacrifiée à l'agriculture intensive
pour permettre à nos supermarchés
d'alimenter leurs rayons
quand on me parle de déforestation moi
j'ai des visages et des paysages qui me
viennent à l'esprit je repense à
l'erreur de l'eau par exemple guatemala
qui a rasé sa jungle sa forêt ses
cultures de maïs qui pourtant toujours à
la base de son alimentation
pour les remplacer par des chants de
palmiers à perte de vue
comment lui en vouloir il a une
communauté une famille des routes une
école entretenir ce qui paie c'est la
demande en huile de palme
et qui demande
je n'ai que trop réalisé que c'était en
changeant notre mode de consommation ici
dans les pays dits développés qu'on
évitera la destruction là bas
c'est l'émotion pour le groupe qui vient
parce que j'étais vraiment au guatemala
pour le coup
quand je suis rentré en france j'ai
monté un local d'information que j'ai
appelé ce monde et graines l'objectif
était sensibiliser mes concitoyens sur
l'absurdité des traités de libre échange
comme le mercosur le taffetas le ceta
qui n'ont vraiment aucun sens qui sont
pour moi à la base de toutes les
problématiques écologiques
comment ont-ils pu faire pour qu'un
légume qui est poussé à l'autre bout de
la planète se retrouvent au même prix
qu'un légume qui est produit localement
à une époque on nous demande de changer
nos moyens de transport remplacer la
voiture par le vélo par le bus les
tomates elles peuvent prendre l'avion
j'ai mis à disposition ce local et c'est
comme ça que j'ai rencontré les
jardinières masqué
semer planter entretenir récolter des
légumes en bas de chez soi dans les
jardins de la ville reconnecter les gens
à la réalité à travers cette simple idée
il n'en fallait pas plus pour que je
rejoigne le mouvement
on marche vraiment sur la tête vous
savez en moyenne une tomate fait 2400 km
en france avant d'arriver dans nos
assiettes alors qu'avec les jardinières
masqués ont fait en sorte qu'elles
passent de main en un
du coup l antiquité ah bon de nous
sommes arrivés à avoir sur nos tables
ces colonies sion qui vient de l'inde en
traversant le canal de suez les villes
ont toujours été constitué par les
espaces d'habitation
d'artisans et d'agriculture on se met
ensemble les graines le printemps et ont
récolté
et ont célébré ensemble on entendre
c'est comme ça qu'on tisser le lien avec
nos voisins
aujourd'hui les gens ont disparu du
centre-ville nôtres si sociale et désire
est
peut-être vous allez me dire
ils sont tous les mêmes ces bobos écolos
ils pensent vraiment changer le monde
le storm plantant des tomates
en fait
nous avons surtout voulu nous
questionner questionner les politiques
questionné nous mêmes les citoyens il ya
des bouts de terre ici la
douce en dessous de vos pieds
quand vous au nom de ses pairs
syli à l'écosystème dans la nature je
suis convaincu qu'il y à aussi
l'écosystème des villes
une ville qui a perdu son moyen de
production dans sa proximité une ville
où on laisse nos voisins isolés dans
leur solitude est une ville fragile et
incomplète
je voudrais également questionné des
pères
les mères
comme moi
plantez les fruits et légumes juste en
mode chez soi
pour moi c'est comme
aller au vote le dimanche c'est de
choisir quel avenir je vous offrir à ma
fille
elle est là ce soir
et avant de rejoindre les jardinières
masqué elle a toujours vécu à paris et
qu'elle n'avait jamais vu
un pied de tomate
du puits elle a appris à planter des
radis des pommes de terre des plants de
fraisiers à faire des boutures de cassis
devait de gozzi et maintenant quand elle
croque ses tomates ça la fait sourire
parce qu'elle est le même
elle en a pris soin
un
enfant a affirmé que les cons comme aux
poussées dans les supermarchés
et oui il a cultivé de tous avec nous
dans les jardinières dans les bacs à
cause de la pollution des sols
ils sont accessibles aux enfants aux
personnes âgées en situation de handicap
adou landes
ils sont tous émerveillés par la
première feuille la première fleur le
premier fruit la première dégustation
un ver de terre qui pointe le bout de
son nez cherchant une feuille à
transformer en terre amie bonjour merci
une abeille merci pour le miel
et pour le pôle elle qu'elle transporte
de fleur en fleur comme le papillon de
toutes les couleurs
c'est tellement beau
cet enfant souhaité faire participer son
école à semer les comestibles dans la
ville il a mobilisé quatre classes et
ils ont eu l'autorisation de planter
dans le jardin des prébendes à tours
ce petit au mythe un géant
cela m'a donné l'idée de proposer des
animations jardin potager dans les
écoles
enthousiasmé les périscolaires les itep
et les universités le développe depuis
mai 2021 en moyenne les municipalités
dépenses par an 46 euros par personne
pour les espaces verts cela fait plus de
cas de ces millions d'euros pour la
ville de tours c'est pour ça que nous
avons lancé une pétition pour que la
moitié de ce budget soit consacrée à
différentes sortes de cultures dans la
ville
nous avons créé des liens d'entraidé de
partage avec nos voisins comme nom de
grenoble poitiers qui partagent
l'initiative
en 2020 la municipalité de tous à
cultiver dans les parcs toutes sortes de
comestible et dans leurs locaux si ils
ont distribué 700 kg de courges et cela
continue en 2021 avec des arbres
fruitiers
le mouvement jardinières masqué lanceurs
d'alerté a été entendu il se transforme
en association pour préserver le travail
déjà fait travailler en co construction
avec la vivre et avec ceux et celles qui
le souhaitent pour les accompagner
nous cultivons simplement en respectant
la biodiversité
l'environnement
apprenons aussi à cultiver à nos enfants
c'est à eux que nous allons laisser
notre belle terre
nous respectons tous les gens même le
voisinage nous cultivons en respectant
tous les êtres vivants
s'organiser en mouvement était une façon
de faire en sorte que tout le monde
puisse se retrouver dans l'expérience
jardinières masquer que chacun puisse
prendre la liberté de venir planter
semer et récolter
seulement en france le jardinage urbain
est illégal oui l'état considère que
planté juste en bas de chez soi ou dans
son quartier est une dégradation la
propriété privée ça nous appartient pas
en sommes donc nous n'avons pas le droit
de cultiver
en refusant publiquement de se soumettre
à cette paix à l'occasion de la
désobéissance civile et cette forme
d'action est douce et pacifique par
nature et nous a permis une certaine
agilité afin de se réapproprier ces
espaces
on s'est donc réuni chaque week-end
autour d'ateliers d'assemblées
citoyennes d'apéritif débat chaque
week-end les propositions les réflexions
les mises en place
parfois on se ramasse mais à chaque fois
en avance et après plus d'un an
d'expérience la municipalité de tours
nous a proposé un projet de co
construction
ça y est nous avons été entendus une
page se tourne mais c'est tout le livre
qu'il faut continuer
planter du comestible dans l'espace
public oui mais en fait pas n'importe où
la terre que nous utilisons vient d'une
forêt de mus que les micro organismes
ont rendu fertile et scène celle des
villes ne peut pas être utilisé
directement pour jardiner en raison de
la pollution des sols c'est à cause des
activités industrielles qu'on y retrouve
des métaux lourds comme le zinc ou le
plomb ces éléments sont essentiels pour
les plantes est naturellement présent
dans le sol mais s'il y en a trop ça
peut être toxique on trouve aussi des
hydrocarbures provenant de la combustion
des énergies fossiles ou encore les
pesticides résiduelle de l'agriculture
enfin bref tout un cocktail de polluants
potentiel alors si nos sols sont pollués
et que nous plantons récolte et mangeons
nos légumes et fruits sont impactées et
c'est notre santé qui est en jeu j'ai
donc fait le par et avec mes études de
biologie végétale et j'ai exploré le
sujet de la phytoremédiation
phytoremédiation signifie remettre de l'
équilibre dans les milieux grâce aux
plantes
un concept loin d'être nouveau puisqu'il
ya 3000 ans déjà on utilisait les
capacités épuratoires des plantes pour
le traitement de l'eau aujourd'hui on
sait que certaines espèces sont capables
d'accumuler jusqu'à 100 fois plus de
métaux lourds que les autres d'autres
peuvent dégrader les hydrocarbures
directement au niveau de leurs racines à
l'aide de champignons ou de bactéries
par exemple cette technique pourrait
permettre sur le long terme de nettoyer
nos sols et de pouvoir espérer laisser
aux générations futures la jouissance
d'un environnement sain et nous on est
là à chercher des solutions ultra
technologique sans même prendre la peine
d'étudier ce qui est déjà naturellement
présents
imaginez quand même la résilience de la
terre
on la pourrit jusqu'au noyau et elle
trouve quand même des solutions pour
nous sortir de là
donc vous voyez il ya encore énormément
à faire en fait c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous sommes 4 ce soir
avec la multitude de nos connaissances
nous avons en tant qu intelligence
collective
car ça n'est qu'ensemble que nous
pouvons trouver des solutions pour
peut-être pouvoir parler un jour de
biodiversité en ville
c'est ensemble que nous pouvons nous
unir pour agir sur tous les fronts et
pour les différents combats qui nous
attend
si on écoute sont un peu plus son
intuition au fond on sait que le monde
tant de parents mais nous pouvons vous
pouvez faire le choix de passer de
spectateurs
acteur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]